- [Narrator] Deep inside
the Greco-Roman City
of Hierapolis lies the most relaxing
and the most visited
site in all of Turkey.
(lively, bouncy music)
From a distance, Pamukkale's
cascading white pools
seem to resemble a
castle of fluffy cotton,
but upon closer inspection,
they reveal themselves
to be solid limestone
walls housing turquoise,
mineral-rich water.
The site is fittingly called Pamukkale,
which translates to
Cotton Castle in Turkish.
Housing 17 hot springs, they
each range in temperature
from 35 degrees to 100 degrees,
perfect for soaking in.
Pamukkale has been used
as a natural bathing spot
for centuries, especially since the water
in each hot spring is
filled with minerals.
It was the Greek and Romans who discovered
that these minerals potentially hold
countless curative properties.
According to many, the
water brings benefits
to the skin, eyes, and
can assist with recovery
from high blood pressure,
making this Cotton Castle
a very relaxing place to visit.
(chiming)